you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return the return return i think of my
dear friend joe derosa who's been coming
up a lot on the podcast we've been
laughing about joe quite a bit so i'm so
happy that he's here and honest to
goodness this whole episode
was like watching a great movie he just
has told the story of what happened to
him
with him in his life not to him but
what's been going on in his life since
he was last on which was years and years
ago and i was like this has the
structure of an incredible film and i
was just
both katie and i were just saying how
much we enjoyed it and i really really
hope you enjoy it as well joe is
incredible and just a lovely lovely
human being if it seems like we're
breaking each other's balls or or
whatever in this episode remember we've
known each other for like a decade over
a decade and we love each other very
much so no shots fired here uh let's get
to it as quickly as possible uh i always
have a stand-up show in los angeles at
largo every month uh the last one bill
burr was on we have had mullany we've
had amy schumer it's always incredible
go to
largola.com for tickets whatever month
you're listening to this
largodashla.com and look for pete holmes
living at largo always the highlight of
my month hope to see you there and if
you're in montreal if you're a canadian
weirdo go to hahaha.com or just search
just for laughs montreal i will be doing
a live podcast live stand up all sorts
of
shows up there it's going to be really
really fun hope to see you there or just
for laughs cancun it's called just for
laughs escapes we're going to be doing
live podcasts live stand up all in
cancun so if you're looking for an
excuse to get away and have some laughs
look for just for laughs escapes as well
all right everybody this episode is
brought to us just one sponsor up top by
our friends at living libations val and
i are we're head to tail a complete
living libations family we swear by
these products they are absolutely
wonderful natural alternatives to the
random chemical nightmare hair skin
teeth products that most people are
buying at 7-eleven i realized years ago
i was being mindful of what i was
putting in my body in terms of food but
i wasn't being very careful about what i
put on my body shaving cream that are
neon blue face washes that i thought
were fancy because they were
sold in outdoor kiosks and malls with
french names but these companies don't
give they don't care about us i was
going to swear they don't care about us
and they're filled with chemicals
linked to disease and toxicity levels
never intended for humans i eat food
where i recognize the ingredients and i
want my skin care to be the same
especially when it comes to leela every
morning because she goes to preschool
now she we usually pick her up and she's
in a in her underwear so she's
completely exposed to the sun
and val and i did a lot of research and
the only truly natural sunblock i've
ever found is the i love the sun zinc
based sunscreen that living libations
sell a lot of them you see on amazon
they might be natural-ish but they're
still filled with a lot of chemicals
they're just kind of skating by the i
love the sun zinc based one is truly
something i can put on my daughter and
not feel kind of weird about it let's be
honest i also use their ginger
exfoliating scrub which is the most
badass exfoliant i've ever used in my
life plus i recognize
all of the ingredients the plants and
the oils and the extracts but it is
truly wonderful and works their zen
shave balm is what i use to shave every
well i only shave a couple times a week
because i'm lithuanian but it's so clean
and natural and moisturizing you can
actually use a dab of it as aftershave
try doing that with well i won't name a
brand but you can't do that with the
canned stuff this is real and natural
and it works and at night best skin ever
moisturizer leaving both val and i skin
looking great feeling great smelling
great
and we use that before bed but whatever
your skin needs this is a great way to
support the show if you would like to
if you have skin needs hair needs face
teeth baby needs living libations i
promise has a premium natural high-end
wonderful product to replace the random
chemical nightmare they sell at cvs so
show your support of the show and show
your support of your body go to
livinglibations.com promo code for this
month for august it's capital weird
capital w-e-i-r-d-88
just capital w so weird 88 and uh and
try it out all these products by the way
they all last a really long time uh so
they some of them might like the
sunblock costs a little bit more but
that little bottle lasts and less and
less and that's true of all of their
products so go to livinglibations.com
promo code weird 88 for 15 off and show
your support of this show all right
everybody hope you enjoyed joe derosa i
always do this was the highlight of my
month i love chatting with him get
into it
um you drink your [__] liquid death
joe
yes for men that can't just drink water
who aren't too insecure
make it look like it's gonna kill
something the first place i ever saw
this water was on a cliff from stevo's
podcast
oh wow of course
he has some water that's like but it
you're gonna die
whatever the hell because he's like
sober but you know well no it's funny it
used to be the sauna and now it's liquid
death because that's now the most
notable that but you said it
that's that's good branding
if it's something that you have to be
like it's like making a pack of
cigarettes that's vitamins i'm not going
to work just where the [__] i'm just
going you don't have to i don't want to
wear them where it's just you and me
we're sitting here
there was like four of us i'd wear
big j okarson
keith robinson
make it a real joe derosa affair i
actually hate first of all
so happy to see you okay oh that's just
it burn in what do you mean you've done
the podcast like three times no i've
only done it twice you did uh we made it
movies as well
oh you're right i did i did and i have a
movie thing to tell you you know what i
did yeah go ahead i just it seemed like
i should have had a glenn gary
that's what i wanted to tell you one of
the one point of which you wanted to
speak to me two of which
this came out a long let me silence the
phone this this this came out a long
while ago i don't know why it's actually
a good burn i feel like if i was
seinfeld and you were tom papa and you
were like let me silence the phone i'd
be like
i wouldn't worry about it i'm about to
mention a seinfeld thing
what the hell universe
what the hell that was weird
yes
that was weird i'm about to mention a
glenn gary and seinfeld thing well we
know signs together loves glengarry as
do we that's what i'm gonna bring out
but do you get the burn i wouldn't worry
about it well that would sound like the
photos i wouldn't worry yeah yeah yeah
like nobody ain't nobody reaching out
yeah it's very funny
it's it's very funny okay good um
i can't believe i've never mentioned
maybe i have and i still remember but
the he does the comedians and cars with
mario joyner mario yeah what are you
doing mario i say mario do you say robot
no but i can't were you raised on the
lower east side in 1920 by a old jewish
woman that remains to be seen we don't
know where you're from i we don't i'm
adopted god only knows no one knows
where it actually started you're like
one of those big bags of candy that you
get scoops
you know what i mean there's no label on
your box it's just scoops
in there or it's like the place that i
was like here's a halloween bag of candy
yeah
that's what you are you're a clear you
don't know what you're getting bag
the factory had a bunch of root beer
barrels left over and they had some
reese's pieces
and that's joe derose
so am i by the way i don't know why it's
so fun to make fun of how we don't know
where you're from because i was italian
because you're not adopted yeah i guess
that's the area
i suppose we're circling in on the area
yeah because if they're when you're not
adopted uh you have two other people
that can uh you know talk about where
you might be from
yeah that's basically it the most
the stupidest man
oh yeah because i could ask my folks
and then ask their folks
you're a bag of halloween candy
what a what a mean thing to say i'm also
a bag of halloween candy i just had two
other similar bags of halloween yeah no
no it's uh but but
the the episode with mario joyner
they talk about how they quote glenn
gary glenn ross all the time that's
right and seinfeld says like he's the
one friend because we are obsessed with
the movie
but then
it
shows the clip and he's and it's like
they're doing like
[__] you that's my name and i'm like you
amateurs buddy you amateurs look you
know we both love the sign sure
absolutely and i have the same
experience because
you and i i'm gonna say it we've
elevated quoting glengarry glen ross
we're we're the uh
something symphony orchestra i can't
even think we're we're the best is that
it's it's we are and they were like
always be closing and i was like i don't
think i've i
i wouldn't go near and always be close i
wouldn't go near that even if there was
like a double meaning someone's closing
a bunch of doors i would never be like
always be glad i got to be honest with
you i won't go near the baldwin's speech
it's too obvious i hear you it's too
obvious we're knee-deep in arkansas
why would you do that
i
yeah no i'm i'm totally there i'm i'm
i'm i'm quoting link
you're quoting the baldwin speech
you can't anything that was on a t-shirt
it's over
it's over coffee is for closers if it's
written on a sandwich board in front of
a of a local coffee shop you can't it
can't be in a glen exactly if it was a
if it was a snl sketch yep forget it
boss baby makes fun of it like because
he's the voice of boss baby yeah he is
the baldwin not seinfeld which i would
have enjoyed the movie
well that's b movie i would have loved
to see baldwin in b movie
and a seinfeld baby
and respect to join her too i've never
met him he seems like a nice guy but the
game was weak i will say
out of sympathy now that i that we've
declared ourselves as the kings of quote
and glenn gary which i know we are we
are pressure's on and i'm a little bit
like i don't know if i can do it today
and maybe they were having an off day
well we don't need to do it you know we
do
it when when jordan sat down to do the
last dance do you think he said i got to
pick up a ball he said no i'm sitting
here ask me the questions i'll answer
them that's great
do you think michael jordan was nervous
when that crew was like setting up like
not at all
he's the he's the most secure man that's
ever lived you think so
well when you look at the dress
yeah the style of dress it's a zoot suit
a seven
hitler mustache didn't bat an eye
did he yeah you don't remember that full
adolph he was in a
i guess he was a haines spokesman for a
while
but uh it was he was a commercial for
something and he had like the little
hitler and that was like the running
joke was everybody talked about like
what's going on with jordan's there's a
lot of laundry slash hitler jokes yeah
but we're not gonna do them yeah yeah
yeah we're not gonna do them there's
also like stained i don't want any of
them okay i don't want any of this i
look to katie
katie got a chuck we're not even doing
it we're doing glenn gary or better uh
yeah most secure man in the world uh
he's he's tom cruise level
i'm okay with myself i'm gonna ask you a
question yeah who between t crews and
michael jordan
which of them has friends like friends
like
mikey it's tony
and he wasn't on a team with him they
don't smoke cigars and play cards
they're just friends i think jordan over
cruz
i yeah yeah cause jordan came from
we don't know
you want to talk about halloween candy
cruise like where's cruz where did he
come from
he was grown like an orokai yeah
you've never heard him talk about his
parents is that true i haven't wow you
know most people you're like
like like oh like robert de niro is
mysterious but then he did the
documentary about his father you know
i didn't know that robert downey jr
talks about his dad once in a while you
know like it's like
so-and-so will say something about it
you know dennis quay is related to randy
quaid you know what i mean like there's
a sibling there's something cruz points
to a serum
and not a shot serum like a gun serum
crews as a matter of fact
can you think of a
normal interview you've ever seen with
cruz there's a lot like it's a fun
rabbit hole to go down is cruise
interviews yeah and i like there's quite
a few where he's he snaps and has had it
he's had it it's a lot of yeah it's a
lot of snaps
it's a lot of
intense like and i put myself to that
test every day ever you know what i mean
yeah there's a lot of that which means
do you think he crashes
does he ever walk around with bad
posture just eating ben and jerry's just
being like maverick maverick i feel down
in the dumps i think it was i think
walsh and i
were laughing about i think it was cruz
where we said he sleeps all night
in the batman upside down
wakes up goes directly to
another upside down batman thing and
gets into it
and that's his day
he starts his day he moves to
he's in an upside down the alarm goes
off he wakes up he lowers himself
walks gently barefoot across his
beautiful floor and just kisses another
one
wide awake now
see because we're the same age we both
have the same image of kim bossinger
basically
i say basinger yeah like a zinger yeah
like a zinger for your bae yeah
hey nice shirt does it come in your size
hey singer
uh but you remember when she wakes up
after
simulated sex that's called in the first
batman because i remember my mom read a
review to see if i could go see the
first batman wait what do you mean it's
called what's called simulation what
what film critics mean at least in the
1990s when they'd say simulated sex
means implied sexuality because in the
first batman remember they you don't
there's no like oh oh god
you're getting a condom out of the
yellow belt
oh jeez like that
yeah it doesn't happen yeah alfred
brings a wet rag for afterwards it's
heated sir
his glasses which have caught gone out
of alfred's glasses in the original
batman went out of style and i think
they're back
yes the little the like john lennon
little yeah
thick linens yeah anyway
little thick linens great title for
something little thick linens you title
the episodes call it little thick linens
we'll title this one that's all right
um
so simulated sex and that she woke up
with the e yeah
uh are you excited about keaton coming
back
i'm beyond excited i'm excited too i
thought because i never know with you it
was fine no i know they're gonna throw
us every [__] thing from the past
but keaton coming back is the thing i
didn't know i ordered and when it shows
up at the table i'm like i ordered well
yeah no i'm i gotta tell you man every
time
i think
there's nothing left like like so like
with star wars right i was just gonna go
there i know you like mandalorian but as
soon as at a certain point
i just was getting saturated i'm not
even saying it was bad i was just
reaching saturation that when obi-wan
came out i was like it's like so much
candy it was so much i want spinach
because there's so much candy it's and
they're not it's not all great yeah sure
i haven't seen it mando boba fett
obi-wan it's like there's a little bit
of good
but there's a lot of i don't need this
they're doing a thing well i'll go back
to my point in a minute but they're
doing a thing now with the star wars tv
shows that i hate
everybody speaks english
there's like no more alien language with
the subtitles
and they're giving i don't like that
because i didn't know i didn't like that
but you just explained it i like a
little talks
like that's fun
and one talks to jabba that cutscene
there's other scenes but when jabba is
talking in in
that's what it's called yeah okay yeah i
i just got directions
i don't know what to do with that but
here's the thing too because everybody
speaks english
and they don't want everybody to be from
england
which is the only space accent that
should ever exist or past accent or
fantasy action yeah exactly a bit about
that because you can't be like you see
that [__] dragon cake well that's my
point they're giving people like
southern accents in star wars i don't
care so you see like an alien with six
eyes and he's like hey y'all get away
from my spaceship and you're like this
is stupid
yeah this is really stupid i'm gonna say
something that someone hasn't said since
1970 when did new hope come out 1977.
1977 there were people that were going
like this is pretty stupid because they
were seeing it comparing it to other
things we loved it it was new it was
fresh what i'm saying is it's always
been skating on thin ice i know that's
hard to believe but it's always been
pretty close to stupid yeah and when you
cross the line it's it's not a far trip
to going into like oh this is all dumb
they've also got this in no offense
because a friend of ours is in star wars
kumail yeah i don't mean this
offensively
can you edit that out
he doesn't even talk like that anymore i
do impression of 2001 kumail now he's
like hello
that wasn't good either but i'm trying
to do it like where are my weights
deadlifts
emily deadlifts but they've got this
thing with the star wars they've got
this thing with star wars where they
keep putting comedians into it and it's
[__] it up for me
i'm sorry
burr with a full-on massachusetts accent
yeah in space yeah
being like eddie empire
oh watchy sounds like edith bunker it's
outrageous
i'm supposed to use the force
who dulls out the force no i'm serious
i'm doing your impression whenever i say
no i'm serious i learned that from you
i'm very proud that i had
arguably the first or second billboard
impression now it's and now it's like
he's so famous it's everyone everyone
has it's like doing a seinfeld
impression yeah yeah but uh santino but
you said santine is good at impressions
mark normand is insane
oh my god yeah it's like because
mark norman is like nicholson everybody
thinks they can do a mark normand
impression that's right but when it's
right you hear a good one that's right
yeah yeah and santino's is right
a lot of us doing nicholson were doing
uh slater
yeah who was doing nicholson right he
admitted to it in your back are you dead
oh yeah he said he was jack nicholson
was the greatest guy who's his favorite
actor
it was like it was
you know
camille uh hugh grant that sounds like a
bit it's his favorite actor this is
going to sound like a bit especially
when he's growing up kind of like
new you know college new to the country
watching movies learning trying to find
role models i guess comedy role
idols icon sure picked hugh grant go
ahead and watch notting hill
it's not obvious but you'll go like oh
yeah
that's where kumail got some of that
like oh yeah well um
that's interesting interesting you would
never guess that woody allen once said
that allen has also seen him
well woody allen once said that he goes
i don't know why everybody thinks i'm so
funny i'm just doing a bad bob hope
impression and in the documentary where
he said it they put a clip of him from
love and death
next to a clip of bob hope and i was
like
holy [__] he's doing bob hope but it's
but he's so woody allen you can't see it
until they show you bob hope
and you're like oh my god it's the same
thing
wow
like wild like wildly identical wow i
actually fly out of woody allen uh
airport here in burbank
that's how much i'll take that
the uh
uh i was gonna try to make some you know
who else flies out of woody allen i
don't know i couldn't think of yeah it's
like the the hitler laundry jokes
they're there there's one there
but but but my original point
with star wars was when star wars came
out i said the new ones i said
this is amazing and this is the last
time my childhood will ever be brought
back to me harrison ford carrie fisher
mark hamill returning
this is the last time i hope you like it
joe yeah and i love the first one you
liked it and then it tapered off from
there oh
i don't know i'd say that right to my
face you know they yeah well
harrison they killed you
and then they made luke an [__] yeah
drinking heaven
they didn't really do a lot with the
legacy as much as they wiped their ass
with it you're right i never really
considered that we're bringing han back
for his son to kill him we're bringing
luke back to be a vagrant on a boring
island
i actually i didn't watch it but there
was a youtube video where they were like
they were humiliating them like
intentionally to like make a statement
this is going to get you wound up just
me even i can't don't make me lose my
voice because it's already teetering i
already said you're like american
splendor yeah
it's
it's constant ever since i had covert
it's it
you have long-haul joe derosa voice yeah
yeah one of the symptoms remember that
list of 85 symptoms that was like was
there one
well there was at one when code first
came out they were like here are all the
you know they were like are you not
terrified enough let us help
we're the news yes
we're here now
were you relaxing just now
i don't know how people do it um i have
a bit my act about it where i i get so
mad when they censor news because
they'll say the video's too triggering
yeah and i go
i know what the goddamn news does that's
why i'm reading it who is walking around
going it's been a [__] day maybe i'll
read some news
i'm greeting it to be triggered that's
the point that's like a warning on
coca-cola being like it may be sugary
yeah but um
but but anyway i said this is the last
time my childhood right then they were
like we're gonna do another indiana
jones and i was like
okay this is the last time and i'm super
excited wait they're doing another one
yeah they're done shooting it within it
with heron yeah it's he said it's gonna
be his last movie this is my last move
which is perfect how perfect is that
this is the last crusade
if i'm being honest
um
uh so so but then and i'm excited every
time so there i'm not i don't do the any
laboof in that one
there
is a picture from set that he's
definitely not in it okay yeah
no boof kate's saying no
the movie went vegan no beef no move
i'm excited every time then they were
like we're bringing back the
ghostbusters and i was like oh my god i
forgot about ghostbus
then they were like
we're what was the thing that got us
onto this to begin with keaton
yes
and then after ghostbusters i was like
that's there's no more childhood and
then they were like kate i was like oh
my god
i think i was only there for keaton how
you are about all of those franchises i
was only about batman you didn't love
ghostbusters as a kid
i remember being a little you're a
little older than i am aren't aren't you
i'm 44. okay so you're two years older
than i am
but that might have been important
because i remember
this is gonna sound so weird but i
you're such a sweet guy secretly i bet
you're actually gonna understand i
remember thinking ghostbusters was a
little too scary and it is pretty scary
and for a comedy for like a this will be
fun and then that
that librarian
shh this started the whole yeah this is
scary thing that we've been doing since
shutter [__] island yeah
no ghostbusters
[__] you
and i thought uh bill murray's character
who i loved from
what was groundhog day before i loved
him
what about bomb it's all after that it's
all after he's got like stripes before
ghostbusters okay then i i don't even
know why i like bill murray but i was
like he's the funny one i'm gonna go see
the funny one and i thought he was mean
he's like mean he is this whole time he
is kind of mean which they call back to
you in the new ghostbusters i got stoned
tonight and it was an okay movie look
ghostbusters has never been good since
the first one
nothing that's what people forget yeah
nothing after it actually believe it or
not the cartoon was pretty good oh i
love the cartoons yeah but the sequel is
not good the remake with the with the
all women one was not good and this new
one
was like a serviceable paint by numbers
reboot
that is now going to have a sequel and i
hope
because i never lose hope
in these types of things yeah yeah like
i hope that that's finally the
ghostbusters sequel we've all really
been waiting for yeah
but probably yeah i'm going to go ahead
and
i'm going to reach into the future and
tell you it's not but you know it's it
is what it is but but
but i love caden i love i i mean keaton
and there's pictures now out there
because he's in this and then he's also
in batgirl
and they're doing batgirl like
the rumor is is they're doing batgirl
like basically batman beyond where she's
he's too old now
and he's got to pass the mantle to
somebody and he's instead of doing a
young guy they're doing a young woman
and it's batgirl quick cue
is her hair flowing out the back
that's bat woman oh i'm sorry yeah
what's bad girl that woman has a big
luxurious red mane of hair because
that's part of the disguise
wait she doesn't really have that no in
real life or you know her her actual who
she is she has like short dark hair
so she has a little bait and switch yeah
i'm like that gives it away but i'm
falling for it that girl does have some
hair coming out you have to
do it because she has hair well i guess
you can't tuck it in that's what the
camel's for i guess she could tuck it in
yeah tuck it in you know she's like an
nfl player with that hair's coming out
talk about
go ahead the worst batman movie that's
ever existed go ahead
robert
i haven't eaten in days pattinson
i didn't know you were going to pick
that one
oh i
i've been meaning to text you because
we're going to do some batman videos
and i'm like we you called him fiona
apple yes so on the record if we end up
doing that if you agree i want everyone
to know that was what you texted me why
first of all thank you because you can't
beat it why is fiona apple
the batman
there's nothing funnier than that i mean
and why is colin
what colin farrell
no andy circuit oh wait colin farrell
yeah
penguin you didn't even know it was him
why are we covering him in 90 pounds of
stuff when we got hollywood boulevards
lined with people that look like that
guy
go to little italy
i mean how many
great
penguins i mean there was rumors that
like before he died they were gonna have
philip seymour hoffman amazing wow
giammod would be a great penguin i can't
believe gmod who i'm talking to right
now
hasn't been the penguin um if you i'm
throwing my head in the ring if you do
batman videos i would love to be a
penguin well you already had patton play
the penguin right oh yeah i'll play
anybody i would just love to be in one
of the videos i'll do anybody yeah i
would love that uh you know i i don't
have to be a major i just want to be a
batman i want to be a character with a
name in one of the videos okay you know
what i mean yeah like somebody from the
comics but it doesn't have to be like if
you got to give the riddler to
james van der beek because you need
clicks or whatever i understand
you know i'll play uh
james van der beek was a great pull
that was a great pull let me play uh the
the uh who's who's who's uh
uh
gordon's partner
the the dirty cop
oh yeah let me play that guy you know in
he's in begins yes
like people think you're gonna open your
mouth that's sort of when yeah when you
don't take money people get suspicious
yeah can i just say he's got the
greatest line and begins by the way
tell me when he's shaking down the
falafel cart and the guy goes come on
man i have children to feed and he goes
what they don't like falafel and that's
how you know
he's about to be hung upside down yes
he's the worst human being
i regularly
routinely because i do a lot of kid
things
see kids that look like that cup
that's a that's a certain face that you
see on kids it's these sad eyes
don't go like falafel and like sometimes
they have the long hair and a little bit
of a wiggum the wiggum knows i met that
guy
you the actor joe you are that guy
he was at a comedy show i did he wasn't
the actor was what he i saw him from the
stage and i was like holy [__] that's
that's did you point it out
no but when i got off stage i went up to
him
and i s he's in he's in tons of movies
uh-huh he's one of those guys like
everything
but i i had that week watched the movie
delirious with john candy and he plays
the cable guy in it
wow and i went up to him and i was like
hey dude it's such a pleasure to meet
you and he was like yeah you were funny
and i go thanks i go i was watching
delirious yesterday and he goes like
that and i go you played the cable guy
in it and he goes
oh oh yeah okay because it was like
[__] 30 years ago
you know yeah
i wonder what that's like for that
like really like is that a good cruising
i i actually would imagine that is a
sweet career to be in 300 movies
as opposed to just being in like 12 as
the lead i mean
you know
those guys they're doing well the the
residuals i'm sure are yeah pretty great
yeah you only need one or two bangers
and the rest are mash yeah
well that's like
now i get it i didn't get it at first i
courtesy laughed
as a courtesy the courtesy the card is
your laugh
go ahead uh at some point i'm gonna
bring this to you
okay to joe derosa michael madsen said
though he was like he's and i love
michael madsen he's one of my favorite
actors but he said he was like
he's like i don't care man i work that's
what i do
you know like his whole thing is like
the dying the shark that stops moving
dies
so that's why michael madsen will be in
like a tarantino movie and then the
following week he's in like some like
to be original action movie or something
you don't even think he's just like i
don't give a [__] right you know i that
was i've quoted this so many times but
paul bettany did this podcast and he was
like i don't know where people get this
idea
that actors are out there like choosing
their careers
i know maybe a couple do but he's like
for the most part i just say yes
i'm picturing him saying this in the
full vision makeup he was wearing the
vision maker
no he wasn't
he's in the i don't know where people
think you get to choose you know
is this too obvious
is this too obvious i'm trying to keep a
cake
okay roses yes one why did you bring
stephen king's on writing i was killing
time after i launched
and i just went for lunch something just
horrible it's so cliche i don't want to
tell you because you're telling me what
it was i'm going to guess corn corned
beef sandwich
not far as big as your head
oh wait you went to booze philly cheese
no no i didn't i didn't okay
very
chicken and waffles no you're closer
with booze
okay
i don't know you're gonna lay into this
no i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
celebrate you jersey mikes
you went to jer you flew to los angeles
and went to jersey mike's you got an
italian didn't you no i actually got a
turkey and a roast beef one oh okay at
least you got to mix animals if you're
joey rose
pat pat walsh room staying with dropped
me off at jersey bikes
and said enjoy your lunch and i said
hoagy should kickstart my energy for the
day
i was kidding
i want to take a nap right
now my god you are so roses so let's
let's let's drop it we're dear friends
i'm so excited to see you it's great to
see you but i also i'm missing a lot of
basics what's meaning like facts we're
real we're real guy friends
we talk about the situations we're in
the problems we're dealing with we're
always there for each other that's true
but we don't necessarily get like the
the updates on like every single element
of your life so since you've done it
it's been years
and i'm just wondering like what's
making roses happy where's rose's been
where does rose's wanna go
the whole philosophy you move back to
new york
places
it's interesting i did i moved back to
new york
city
uh
with the intention of
becoming
more proactive
in my day-to-day life career-wise
meaning doing more stand-up
i had a really good three-year
run out here when i when as soon as i
landed things started happening
at woody allen internationally woody
allen international airport once he
landed yeah
but yeah it's you you
you well i came out because you hired me
so that was the first thing so that was
my first tv
that was my first tv
real writing job i had written here's
the backdrop you know yeah there you go
ranking manager there it is i had
written for tv before but it was always
as a consultant it was a week here a
week there but
so i got that job i flew out moved out
for that
within two weeks after being here i got
a new manager
who i'm not with now but she was great
and we did a lot of good work together
um
within a week of signing with her
i landed the lead in a cartoon pilot for
fx
with like
jenny slate and cherry terry and all
these amazing people
um didn't get picked up but still was
cool
two weeks after that i got better call
saul
the vet yeah
did your show for the duration it was on
went right into
wet hot american summer
writing on that
you mean crashing
no no no no no no no the pete holm show
yeah yeah went right into the red hot
american summer
from without american summer went into
jeff and some aliens so writing jobs
were one after the next yep
got my hour special
came off of jeff and some aliens
did
some shorter writing stuff worked on
moshe casher's
crashing was at the end um
went to
booked the cbs6 i was like when's
crashing coming yeah yeah
booked a cbs sitcom right
and
which i still go i don't know why
i know exactly i trimmed the roses from
that i know exactly what i don't trim
the roses i can tell you why you trimmed
the thorns around the rocks yeah yeah no
i can i can tell you why but we'll i'll
tell you later but anyway the uh and
then and then crashing right
and then
came a very very dry period you know i
left crashing because i wanted to focus
more on stand-up
all of a sudden venues out here started
closing
that i got stage time at
you know promises of
you'll be on the wall next year at the
store and you'll be a regular
kept getting postponed another year
right
character gets cut
from the sitcom
manager drops me
and it's just
a movie
continue working like this
are you in bed smoking cigarettes and i
basically said yeah yeah and keep
working like that yeah yeah
i said i'm gonna leave new york unless
we can do a better job together because
i'm not
getting the attention i need
for these projects to get rolling and
then she called me and dumped me
like it was her i don't want to get into
it anyway
but um
so that all happened right movie i was
working on that i had
sold
just fell through wasn't going to happen
i had sold a pilot to true tv pilot
never even we never even got to shooting
because there was multiple talent it was
me and some other people
and negotiations fell apart in the
talent negotiations and not on my behalf
but on somebody else's
it was just one [__] hit after the
next yeah so you had this like great
ascent yeah then a pretty steep descent
yeah
and
i did not like the day-to-day life out
here it's not my personality it doesn't
fit my personality especially as a
perpetually single guy
this is not a town hard place to be
single yeah very much yeah
and
i was single here
yeah but you were also working when
you're working and you're single it's
fine
you know you gotta have one you gotta
have one yeah you can't be single and
not working yeah then you're just the
guy at the grocery store trying to get
some kismet going with anybody you see i
said to dana gould the other night i go
because he was asking me why when it
went you know like what made you move
and i told him this whole story and i go
dana
you hit a point where you're sitting in
your apartment going how many podcasts
can i create
like it's like you know what i mean
because you're just trying to be busy
yeah i also have some human connection i
would imagine yeah sure yeah but um
but this was the this was the kicker um
i saw
i saw bobby lee
i just saw bobby yeah i'm gonna see him
later today actually but i saw him and
and and he really gave me an amazing pep
talk
and he was like he's he i was like bobby
i haven't worked in basically two years
at that time
and i go i just don't i'm done i don't
want to be here anymore and he was like
two years is nothing
i went five years without working like
like this is what this is something's
about to happen
and i was like okay and he's like go
[__] work at the
the store won't pass you go work at the
[__] laugh factory man
and i was like okay it was this great
pep talk
and then i saw marin two minutes later
because i was like you should hang it up
well done
it's funny i had told burr i wanted to
leave and i guess he told maron
and i saw marin two minutes after he
sold bobby and baron goes so i heard
you're pussing out man
that's what oh i could have seen either
angle yeah i could have seen the mirror
and that goes like i [__] get it dude
eddie you gotta protect yourself ain't
nobody gonna look out for you yeah no he
was like come on man
and then you know why joe can i interact
interact please interject
because you're the best thanks man as
you're doing all of this you know i'm
always
we haven't yet done it but there's got
to be the joey in the homes thing again
but i'm like it's about you it's over
black and this whole story of how
everything was falling apart
and we start yeah the movie starts
i would launch a great rise of the roses
i would love to do something with you of
course and i mean that i always we
always have fun and and you can pay me
in fiona apple jokes
but here's the thing so um
excuse me so
there's a half very happy ending to all
this no i know
i'm just this is the lead up right
so i go to the
marin didn't say anything else
the funny thing was that he said was he
goes
so what what is it about this play he
goes i get it man you can't get the
charge here like you get in new york man
i get it but what else don't you like
and i go
i just don't think i'll meet my wife
here and he goes
your wife
look at yourself which was very funny
uh that is
that's the opening scene yeah it was so
funny
look at yourself
it's with mark maron
that that's the opening scene it's me it
should be talking about talking to mark
mary and we're having coffee and i go i
don't think i'll meet my wife and your
wife look at yourself and that's the end
of the scene oh it's a short scene yeah
yeah it's almost like the beginning of
pulp fiction i know everyone says that
but you're just kind of drinking it you
know what else is to be opening to bad
guys starring mark maron the cartoon
guys yeah you see because of leela i
know bad guys but there's a cartoon
with uh
with uh what's his name sam rockwell and
mark maron are the leads and it's a kid
show it's a kid's movie oh well that's
cool that was really good um
sorry so marin says we're getting to our
happy ending
so anyway so i go
i go i'm going to stay
and i did stay for another year and i
did go work at the laugh factory
and it was the worst place you could
ever work
so funny i love that this story to
generations of americans if they didn't
know what was going on and they just
heard this audio playing from the clouds
they would just assume you went and
worked at some factory yeah and i like
that your feeling toward it was that it
was like working in a factory
i went in the show like it was like my
third spot
the sh and i remember it's funny the
first night i had a show there bobby lee
was on the earlier show and i went
to the girl from the box office goes i
have a note for you and it was from
bobby lee and he said oh well look who's
getting spots at the lab you know it was
actually very his advice that's a sweet
little little christmas card i have the
notes still that's what's like i have a
box of memorabilia what if i have a box
of stuff i've been meaning to burn yeah
and uh but i still have it
but yeah like so
you know nothing against the laugh
factory it is what it is it's a certain
type of club it was not for me
and i just didn't fit in and it just
didn't work
and i said
after a year i was like okay i gave it a
year did you take your thermos and your
lunch pail and just walk out with dusty
boots yeah yeah yeah yeah
hung the hat
block out
you should have to clock in at the left
back yeah you should
yeah
jigs
we both my voice wasn't [__] up i
could have done it
every show should start with that yeah
and then
yeah you have you ever noticed that
balls kind of look like like like that's
the factory starts doing it you have to
do your set sitting on an iron beam oh
my god yes
tonight's lineup
and your feet are dangling yeah like you
date cook
major ronnie i don't know who it is a
lot uh so many of the people that when i
was doing it more aren't around so so it
gets the night gets darkest before the
dawn it gets darker but then it gets
very bright so i moved back to new york
which is hard to keep you in the dark at
that long you got fritos on your face
and then it's so bright it's
dude it's got a little cigarette in your
hair the moving back to new york
i i hate to give every detail but
they're all so important
the moving back to new york was the most
stressful move ever of my life
i had
almost no money like i had just burned
through anything i had acquired because
i had been working
and
the move was so expensive
and it's one of those brutal lines and
extras where he goes because remember
ricky gervais's character andy yeah is
trying to work and he's just being an
x-ray and you know it's not paying very
much he's like i got savings and his
nemesis goes the pile it dwindles
it's the most brutal thing to say yeah
the pile it dwindles referring to it as
a pile yeah is just so it's the whole
thing yeah it's brutal so you're pilot
because of the move
i had done i was moving right before
christmas and because of the move and
the way it was planned or timed you know
the only way it could
and then it budding right christmas i
would have like and then it budding
right up against christmas your favorite
holiday my favorite holiday and then me
having to go home to my mom's for
christmas i remember this on christmas
eve
my friend goes so you're finally fully
back and i go
i haven't slept on a bed in a month
and he was like what do you mean and i
was like they took my bed for the move i
had to sleep on a couch i got to my
apartment i didn't have a bed yet i had
to sleep on a couch an air mattress then
i got a couch they delivered my bed the
day i left to come home for christmas
i've been sleeping on my parents couch
in the guest room i was like i haven't
slept on a bed in a month i haven't
eaten
yet
and
on top of it all
i took this little
shitbox apartment in like an old
tenement building in new york why
it was easy to get it was in a great
location and i wasn't going to be there
because i was going to be doing stand up
yeah so your cops melania i used to call
it cop's apartment yeah right you just
need a venetian blind to stare out yeah
occasionally and homes i'm talking like
truly only window was in the bedroom
only sink was in the kitchen no sink in
the bathroom yeah yeah yeah like true
like
low-level new york [__] you know and um
what floor
like third like just high enough that it
was a pain
you know what i mean not high enough to
be a luxury yeah not low enough to be
easy yeah yeah no elevation it's a great
story i my heart hurts for the joe that
was suffering but i'm also like this is
a good story man it's kind of it's it's
so so and it was a dirty building it was
like a dingy [__] building right
but
i start doing tons of stand-up i go back
sd starts using me at the seller paul
and or patrick
are using me all the time at the same
time that happened just out of curiosity
i i if i'm sd joe derosa shows up boom
is that how it happened more or less i
love it yeah she was just i'm not
surprised i was just pausing in case
there was some
i like those moments where somebody like
jim norton goes like come on yeah you
didn't need that at that well and that's
the thing it's like it's like i had been
gone for so long and that what i didn't
realize was that my stock rose a bit
rosa yeah because you know yeah you add
all these things people it's actually
cool here in l.a you're like
it's been five years i was on joe and
some aliens yeah yeah and we're all kind
of like okay what are you gonna do next
then you go anywhere else it's like you
wrote
on five shows yeah yeah i know it's cool
[__] crazy right yeah it's very cool
and i'm glad you got a little uh a
little tip of the cap and um
so
i'm doing stand-up i'm i'm walking
i remember one weekend like and i would
just i would do those those two clothes
i'd do new york comedy club and you
could walk
so i was walking
yeah it was like decent weather you know
for december
i was like briskly walking from set to
set it was exercise i'm coming home i'm
like man i made 1500 bucks this weekend
doing [__] spots like this is stupid
i'm back baby i'm doing you know i'm
like now i'm going to do the road and
this and that right and i'm so excited
this was the right move
and covet hits
i
how many movies
should
be made yes where that's the the comp
that's like the inciting incident it's
like we have this story we're invested
you have your [__] apartment but it
doesn't matter you're doing spots you're
one taking walks
yeah
[__] comfort it hits
roses is back yeah
and the universe is like got a mask
oh my [__]
hits
brutal and i'm in new york belly of the
beast you have coveted literally one of
the
look i know it did fine it's actually
one of the first places that sort of
bounced back too oh because it was the
first place that went down exactly i
remember being glad i wasn't in new york
it all started there
it's funny we all said the same thing
about california when it came out here
because we were looking at it like
we've done that sorry guys yeah that
sucks man you know like but like um
covet hits so i'm in a essentially
windowless apartment yeah
it's it's it's gross i it's cramped i
know this is the story but i am just
taking a moment
to in horror appreciate that you rented
an apartment
on the full knowledge that you just
would quote and this is a quote
i'll never be there right
no you're about to be there for two
[__] years yeah dude it's like
dude because i thought
cause i thought like
my friend who got me the apartment was
like you could break the lease like
don't worry you know what i mean like he
was because he was a real estate agent
he was like don't worry about it
so i was like i'll just [__] crash
here for now i'll find something better
yeah and then cover was like no you
won't like this is it wow so i'm stuck
in the apartment now combs keep in mind
i'm not just stuck in the apartment i'm
stuck in the lightless apartment
the only way to get outside
i can't is to walk
into
the hallway that looks like it invented
covid inside of it
it's that gross
and it's a time where every news thing
is like
don't touch any surface
remember they were like don't touch your
face here's the thing
our kids yeah are gonna be like mommy
and daddy had a time when the news was
like don't touch your yeah wipe down
your cell phone i'm leaving the
apartment for one reason and one reason
only to get food groceries yeah and then
go back and hold up they really are
gross
folks
you're talking about new york grocery
stores
yeah they're already like this yeah yeah
yeah it is the worst case scenario i'm
sitting in my apartment
i had a mental [__] br and um by the
way i'm off
i'm not i haven't i haven't been on meds
in forever i'm not in therapy
and it all just crashes down and um
uh i i had a breakdown on a zoom with my
parents
to the point where they were like
we want to come get you your dad is the
billy crystal thing i think
yeah yeah if i'll call you back
they were like we want to come get you
but we can't
because of covid
but we think you might kill yourself
really yes it was that bleak yes
i was literally on a zoom going he could
take you on yes yeah
i was going i'm i'm
i moved back here to do
a thing that i may never be able to do
ever again because nobody knew what the
[__] was going on wow
so what was that call like crying
i wasn't
joking my mom was crying i was like
full-on fury
wow like [__]
this [__] world
if you're up there [__] you too like
screaming up at god and [__] like that
your upstairs neighbor is like what did
i do
yeah yeah like like really dramatic but
like true like true book of mormon like
yeah i was furious wow and the musical
not though and then i had friends
calling me being like are you okay like
who called
um give some love shout outs to these
people
he was like my cousin
no it was yeah
yeah no like well well here was the big
one this was the main one
oakerson called me
and he was like
let's
let's go somewhere
me and you and like sal sauer falcano i
do tastebuds with he was like let's
i call him new pete but yeah yeah
no that's just because he's so funny and
you guys have such great rapport i'm
like [__] you man that's my guy
it's only out of love and out of respect
for his talent
i know i know but in case he hears that
i'm not actually mad at it i'm sure he
would get it yeah but it's like when you
see someone else with you with one of
your best friends like having your
rapport yeah you don't like it you don't
like it hey so he goes uh jay goes let's
go somewhere we got to get we got to get
out of the city like we'll be careful
we'll all test dude this was like by the
way
we had to get home tests through a
doctor
that was like these are half reliable
like they didn't even have tests yet it
was great
during that time did big j go from
fingerless to fingered gloves i believe
yeah full-fingered no no
latex club
cut off disposables
we'll be safe we won't share parliament
yeah yeah
yeah he got them from uh punk rock
hospital
supplies.org there's a way to do cbgb
and there's a hospital that's like
letters there's a way to do it i don't
have something right yeah
c-b-g-y-n
something like that obcbgyn
i knew we could get there
obc gyn
so
he goes he goes let's go somewhere and
like get out of the city
like we're going crazy here yeah dude it
looked like [__] i am legend it was
it was horrible yeah
and it's getting slapped left and right
dude it was just so well
so
so he goes let's go somewhere and i said
jay i'm embarrassed to admit this i
literally can't afford it
and he said
let me
pay for you
and i said no no no no i can't do that
i'm
really humiliating and he said when
somebody
he said he gave me i forget what the
story was he told but he said when i
needed something
so-and-so gave it to me yeah let me do
that for you as a friend which was
amazing yeah so we rented this house
and i did eventually pay him back when
everything settled but that's what we
were all thinking
this beautiful story did you pay him
yeah i did i did it with interest yeah
yeah with no no
uh
[__] you you're the one who wanted to be
kind
here's your investment
full stop
you don't help a friend to turn a profit
don't spend it all the same gloves
so we go
away
and
where did he go we just went up to the
catskills we just rented a house
and um and it was really good for the
soul and i really bonded with sal we
weren't doing our podcast yet i i kind
of i was friendly with him i didn't know
him very well yeah
but we really was when you became taste
buds it's it's not yet almost oh yeah
but but
uh we we we bonded we just really got
along and then which by the way if if
you guys are getting along like this
during this time you deserve to be the
new homes yes
this homes is a travesty this whole time
i'm sort of like where was home
i mean what do you mean where you you
were dealing with your life no i know
it's not even i spoke to you during all
that yeah we spoke yeah it's it was a
terrible time i just wish there was
something we could
have all
take that mario
so out of that came this thing where we
started a text thread and we we titled
it the crew and it was like we had a
covid crew finally this is so beautiful
yeah and we had like a family can i slow
it down a little bit what did you do in
the catskills
did you not because
if you leave it to my writers it's gonna
be shower curtain uh backdrop and you
guys do stand up with a broom
like i can't picture what you did we had
um booze it wasn't a lot of drinking we
had two nights where we like partied it
up with drinking yeah
um
featuring drinking a lot of like group
cooking oh wow a lot of like huge like
dinner was huge it was kind of like in
goodfellas when they're in prison
it was like the event of the day was
dinner oh my god this is heavy this is
like the third act of chocolate yeah
it's really
melting my heart
heavy dessert cigarette dangling from
his mouth flipping a pancake making
crepes
he's making he's got to be making
something super fancy of course like
it's the cigarettes
and they're immaculate yeah yeah and
there's sal putting clams on his pizza
yeah jade half ass cigarette reduction
at table side yeah he has a pan with a
like a perfect reduction in it
um uh
truly great
um heavy desserts
like full like the desserts were heavy
are just lots of desserts like we got
like
like a smorgasbord amount of desserts
like like a like like hotel casino
buffet dessert this is as beautiful as
valerie's like girls trips to joshua
tree menstruating in the desert sand
howling at the moon brightening each
other's hair did he's floating in the
hot uh massage circle that would have
been if that was a homes monologue you
would have done it in the i would have
in the toucan voice by the way remember
yes used to be a multi-colored beak
meant something in this town
that was my favorite joke ever i didn't
remember i knew it was referred to as
the two gang voice it's the joe derosa
voice and i we
are posting on my instagram old pete
holmes show monologue so i watched them
to approve them and i'm like wow i went
to that a lot and it really is a credit
to you as a performer and as a writer
that i found the jodaro's attitude of
like you think you're gonna do better
like it's not exactly you but we
wouldn't have had it without you but we
had yeah it was you had to have but the
toucan joke was yours
sure when we went to the zoo
the two the lions are
sprawling acres of land
you look over the bird that can fly
is it a
phone booth two by two
and then the toucan says a multi-colored
beak used to get you something
and you're throwing the cigarette as you
said
god i i hope you feel that way about
when i watch pete home show clips i'm
just filled with like
boy it was just a big sleepover i it's
it makes me laugh so hard and i remember
nate
uh nate and i forced you
to put the snake
room joke in and it bombed but we were
like it's funny you're wrong
that
the snakes are still
they're they're like the guys in the spa
they go you go in it's a cobra with a
towel around his neck you can see his
snake balls
and we and you were like that's not
funny it's not a joke and we're like
it's [__] hilarious and it it ate it
it ate it in the monologue we ended up
cutting it out it might have been my
fault and telegraph that little glint of
like i don't believe in this joke you
know what i mean yeah we should have
flown you in and you could have done it
and flown out it would okay but anyway
so
that was a huge turning point moment
it's beautiful it would be a movie it
was awesome it's truly beautiful it's
funny and there's lots of stories about
steel magnolias and ladies doing it but
this is very
beautiful when i say feminine i just
mean nurturing i understand life-giving
men can be that way we did three trips
altogether the crew yeah
and
on the
third one is when taste buds was born
wow no i'm sorry i'm wrong the second
one okay we were in the hamptons uh
that's that's another story for another
time let me let me stay on track here so
well let's go to that story after this
one we'll get to it so
we leave that place i'm
spiritually
reached soulfully i should say recharged
yeah
i have people like
hearing it and i care about and i'm not
alone
and that's the beginning of the turn so
then
i call my i on that trip homes my god i
almost buried the lead on look at me i'm
actually giving a gift away
suck seinfeld
for anyone wondering any time we're
saying something that doesn't make sense
it's from glengarry ross
uh
so
but that's how good we are at it because
you got
the words that i'm referencing were not
the reference that was the tone
sometimes it's just it was the
inflection in cadence
sometimes the reference is just
borrowing the the staccato rhythm of a
line yeah yeah wet out there tonight
perhaps yeah yeah
what out there yeah
yeah cuddy owl
uh
so on that trip get the truck here's
where it all changes right okay on that
trip
i get back into therapy there we go
via telephone yeah
this wonderful woman johanna
and she's like calls me and she's like
they
gave me your info and i can do sessions
with you over the phone wait your
friends got you joe hannah no no no i
called my doctor and then okay you know
healthcare stuff
then
and she goes i'm getting you back on
prozac you
you got it something you're off
yeah she starts me back on prozac i get
the first prescription while i'm on the
trip
i go and i just so i start the medicine
for here in all ways and here with the
friendships
i get the call on that trip
from
new york state new york whatever gov
they're like
you're
you have qualified for financial
assistance and you can actually go on to
unemployment now and we'll pay you
it was like 700 a week or something
which at the time was i i so desperately
[__] needed money yeah
and then like what was your rent i'm
just trying to crunch the number two it
was like 2 100 bucks it's like that's uh
that's like your rent yeah it was
basically right well
700 but i hadn't paid rent in two months
and my landlord was okay with it oh wow
because nobody was paying rent because
of who's your landlord john denver
don't worry about it joe
yeah late friend
in my mailbox
did i mention i lived on sesame street
stuffy's a very good landlord um
so that happened
i then like get the sba call
where they're like you're incorporated
you qualify for a grant and a loan
so now all of a sudden i have money back
in my pocket
and i can think straight for five
[__] minutes yeah and i did what was
right i started paying rent again
i didn't [__] around you know like i
didn't try to take advantage of anything
i was like i need this to get back to
where i need to be
so that happened i got friends
and i and i and i can feed myself i can
think straight again
then they announce you can't get it from
surfaces and all these things
then they
the antibody tests come out i get the
antibody test i had the antibodies
because apparently i had covered oh wow
so like all everything is like finally
just starting to brighten and in this
moment
i'll never forget the day it was the day
i found out i had the antibodies and it
was the same weekend they announced you
you can't get it from surfaces
and i left my apartment for the first
time without fear
i walked around new york it was sunny it
was beautiful
i went to and you will make fun wendy's
and got
to squire burger to go food for the
first time yeah because i wasn't afraid
of somebody touching me
even
even i can't touch that yeah it's a
lovely story and i went and i sat on us
on the steps of a building in new york
and ate lunch and i was like
i [__] love new york
and i called my parents i almost started
crying i called my parents and i said
i said um
i realized something i'm not here
because i want to do stand-up i'm here
because i want to live in new york wow
and i was like that's huge i don't care
if i can't do stand-up i still want to
live here
i care if i can't do it but i yeah
that was a huge moment
and in the movie or on the steps of like
the public library or something we need
some good steps yeah and i get up and i
run and the pigeons fly
and because you you take one and dip it
in ranch dressing and just just fight it
set off like ozzy osbourne
and it freezes as the blood is squirting
out
the end some people stand in the
darkness baywatch theme place
um
the greatest freeze frame ending of all
time by the way is the movie easy money
treat yourself if you've never seen it i
haven't seen it the greatest greatest
freeze frame of all time is the end of
easy money
well i did tell you let's let's not
forget where we are in the story that i
was like i i'm in need i love being a
dad i love having a daughter but and
yeah it's not even but it's and i just
don't have any i'm like a i'm a judd
apatow character in the first act where
i'm like i just need some guides
just need some bro time so i was like
some dumb ass movie
and i'm really excited it's really
interesting man like for real for real
there's like i i never really identified
as a as like a super
guy guy right but as soon as i was with
two women
and doing a lot of like nurturing
guy uh girly not girly i know what you
mean though fraternal paternal whatever
uh maternal
taking care of a baby and then being a
husband when they would leave and would
be having like the most idyllic days and
as soon as they left i'd have like 30
minutes to myself i'm watching sicario
like i couldn't wait to see the bodies
in the walls
i was like all the parts that i would
normally skip i'm like show me the drill
going right into the whatever it is
i i had like this weird it's not weird
we're like we're men joe yeah we're
about you're cycling through the rocky
just the matches of all the movies yeah
yeah exactly
there's been a real need there's a need
there there is there is yeah yeah uh
but you know should we show something
women
perfect
so
so i um
so that was an amazing day and that was
a realization and then
cut two a few months later it's the
summer time is this the taste buds one
yeah okay i go
right here
let's go to the mid-roll ad so people
aren't shocked by it and when we come
back i want to hear the birth of taste
buds on the second trip okay we'll be
right back
this podcast is sponsored by our friends
at better help life is full of twists
and turns we know this stress change
grief moments of growth and moments
where we all feel like we're taking a
few steps back and it's important to
show up for yourself through all of the
struggles that life can bring and better
help online therapy is here to help with
the twists and the turns and will assess
your needs and can match you with your
own
licensed professional therapist in less
than 48 hours therapy hands down has
changed my life has changed valerie's
life it's greater than the sum of its
parts you think it's just talking to a
professional or talking to another human
for some reason the way human beings are
built it helps way way more than you
think it's going to that is absolutely
true and has changed the trajectory of
my life in a huge and wonderful way it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help
it's professional therapy done securely
online and the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log in from
your account anytime anywhere and send a
message to your therapist you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
or
so you won't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
that could be awkward in real life it's
much better to do it this way it's more
affordable than traditional therapy as
well offline therapy is more costly and
financial financial aid is even
available better help is a great way to
show up for yourself and invest in your
well-being because well you deserve some
inner peace visit their website and read
their testimonials that are posted daily
go to betterhelp.com
reviews visit
betterhelp.com
weirdo that's better
h-e-l-p and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they're recruiting additional therapists
in all 50 states so a special offer for
weirdos get ten percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com
weirdo thank you to betterhelp for
supporting this show this ad is also
brought to us by our friends at
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept a log of
every single thing you did every minute
of the day that would be pretty creepy
right well what if i told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online
your internet provider is allowed to
store logs of every website you've ever
visited and can legally sell this data
to anyone that's why i always use
expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider can't see or
log what you do online many of you may
be wondering well if i'm routing my data
through a vpn doesn't that just mean the
vpn can see what i'm doing and log my
data instead it might be right to think
that many vpns claim to have a no logs
policy but they've been caught logging
customer activity guess what expressvpn
is the only vpn i trust because they use
trusted server technology
they were the first major vpn provider
to engineer all of their vpn servers to
run in ram that means it's impossible
for their vpn servers to store any data
in hana data including logs of any
expressvpn customer and if you don't
take my or expressvpn's word for it
expressvpn is so confident in their no
logs claim they even had one of the
biggest assurance firms price water
house coopers audit their technology
it's no wonder that the verge named
expressvpn the number one vpn in the
world so stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit expressvp
weirdo right now to find out how you can
get three months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
weirdo
w-e-i-r-d-o expressvpn.comweirdo
to learn
more
all right
back at it
and we're back okay
i go to
we go away
again um
this this was a
this was a huge moment
sal and i are in the hou we're in the we
went we rented a beach
house not not on the beach but a house
at the shore i mean
uh and where we and there was a pool in
the backyard which plays into it
we're in the house
we're cooking breakfast
uh
i can't wait for what the first topic
was a [__] someone eats a cheez-it
he he goes to make a bagel and makes a
remark
about the bagel selection first of all
bagel i know it's one of those words i'm
getting creamed we did we did taste buds
with the ru garbage guys this week and
they'd picked they fought for bagel
bites and they made fun of me the way i
said bagel the whole time yeah um i'm
not even making fun i'm just noting that
that's how they say it in minnesota yeah
well
am i mario back yeah anyway
mario
uh am i from minnesota
i'm a bag of candy
getting toasty huh yeah uh so
anyway so um
we're we
he because i had bought cinnamon raisin
and plain
and he's like why are there no
everything bagels why would you not and
i go
the [__] once at everything bagel and we
start arguing he's like it's the what
are you talking about it's the best
bagel i was like no it's not cinnamon
raisins but and we started arguing i'm
with sal on this one
we started arguing and pete
the other people in the house were like
jumping in whatever
and sal goes this is like when we fought
about the cookies on the joker's cruise
because in practical jokers as a cruise
and on that cruise we fought about chips
ahoy and oreos and i go oh yeah this is
which side did you take on that chips
ahoy i hate oreos um
so
i don't think we can let that slide i
don't like her you go ahead take the
jacket off
i should have told you
now we go to the mid roll go to play the
mid-roll ads again i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
so
i'm gonna need more on that oreo subject
but yeah well there's a whole episode of
taste buds about it i can't be i can't
be jumping to another podcast i'm
already listening to this one
so anyway so so
we're arguing
screaming
screaming about begging one of my
favorite things about you is you'll get
real worked up about some basic [__] in
the middle of it he goes
is this a podcast and i was like
yes i think it is you look down and
squarespace is already there yeah what
yeah i look down
they've got yeah the dollar shave what's
the [__] yeah
i was trying to remember the name of the
electric toothbrush that everybody
adverted quib quibs
quibby whatever the [__] quip yeah
damn it
six cbd companies
yeah and a gambling app i think
i i feel like i was one of the early
adopters to cbd keep going um so anyway
so
i go yeah it is
and he goes
what would we call it and we sat
for an hour in the living room it's 10
30 in the morning
so from 9 30 to 10 30 we sit in the
living room trying to figure out what we
would call it by the kitchen clock yeah
the kitchen clock and then he looks at
me and he goes
shouldn't we just be thinking about this
with an ice cold beer in the pool right
now and i go
and like i lit up so much the idea and
he started laughing at how excited it
made me and he crossed to me and hugged
me
and while he had me in his embrace he
said don't you dare ever move to la ever
again
and we went to the pool oh my god and
had the best day new homes better homes
and at 4 p.m i exclaimed taste buds
oh my god
i always wonder is there an ear buds
is there like a music music file there's
got to be got to be an earbuds there's
got to be right earbuds
if there's not let's do it do it it's
not for me i'd just be i'm saying if
it's not you i would copyright it if i
were you and oh okay sell it to the poor
sap that does what i'm doing five
percent of your crib
so anyway and did you do a little jig of
celebration you can just point that at
joe we can stop the oscillator no you
don't have to point it i want to be a
sweaty egyptian
that was very fast
um
but but it was
so so the the importance of that part of
the story is is it's a beautiful story
it's beautiful and it's it's the
deepening of the friendship but it's
also
now
i have this podcast
and the
podcast very luckily takes off
so now
it's like i really wanna
i wanna argue orgos with you we we will
we will
by the way
and then that
and me and patty are still doing our
podcast with the movies
and and
that was doing okay it was doing pretty
well but then taste buds popping made
we'll see you in hell pop more
so now all of a sudden i'm like
holy [__] man really it didn't split
your audience it actually grew both of
them
it grew we'll see you on hell jumped
significantly from taste buds wow why
did you talk about cu and hell i would
plug it all the time and i'd say if you
don't get enough of me complaining here
about food you can hear me complain
about movies on this other show
with another nice man who puts up with
it named pat walsh who kind of has sal
vibes
a little bit yeah a little bit
so so they don't immediately take off it
takes time but they they by the way set
when i say taste buds
we started recording taste buds
months after creating it there and then
we didn't launch it until a month so my
point is is by the time
all the
the the help money is running out
money is actually starting to come back
into my life again and actually have a i
have a career again
where something is making money
amidst all of this happening yes
uh
i'm
with paul italia who owns the stan
comedy club and is one of my best
friends in the world
we're sitting here sounds like an alias
he does this
jim sicily
oh no cecilia
we're sitting on his roof
we're looking at all of the stores that
are closed in new york
uh
and he says
everybody is jumping ship
but it's the people that stay that'll
survive so if you ever had a thing you
wanted to do now's the time
and very passively i go i just wanted to
open a sandwich shop
and he goes yeah he comes over to me he
hugs me and goes don't you ever move to
la again holmes
he goes what are your sandwich ideas i
tell them to him he goes we're going to
do it as a pop-up at the stand
whoa and we start in the middle of you
had five minutes on sandwiches
you did your sandwich set and he passed
you
basically provolone basically underused
cheese yeah
so that's that's what was the saying
what was the sandwich that like
made you different
because it was a concept it was an idea
speaking of it as an idea
we're destroying science tell me
i hope someone forwards this to them
yeah i do too
they'll probably yell at us
i know uh boy i've had speaking glenn
gary i've had seinfeld on the hook to do
this podcast for four years now how
great would that be yeah it would be the
best that would be the best so tell me i
i do mean it though i'm curious what is
the joey rose's sandwich that you think
made you worthy because it's doing well
and it i didn't worry
it was
what what excited paul was the concept
of it which was i was like it's eight
sandwiches they're eight dollars a piece
and what we're going to do is we're
going to give people
10 times better of sandwich they can get
at subway and we're going to beat
subway's price it's literally and i said
this on ryan sickler's show yesterday
it's american gangster
it's when denzel goes i'm going to go
right to the source and get the heroin
myself can i sell it for half the price
i actually love that movie it's a great
movie it's a great movie yeah no one
talks about that movie yeah it's they
came after my wife yeah my favorite part
is when he goes he goes he go where he
goes he goes you don't scrub that you
pat that when he's mad about his rug
that's a twenty thousand dollar carpet
i've fired i've seen him somebody
spilled something on his rug i've seen
it so many times couldn't tell you that
so it kills me you pat that he's so mad
anyway um
so i tell paul this idea and he's like i
think that idea is great and he was like
and then when i told him to sandwich
ideas i was like these are like things
these are variations of sandwiches i
grew up with
like and you can't get these in new york
why the [__] can't you get an italian
sub in new york and when you do it's 17
and it sucks why am i going to a corner
bodega to get an italian hoagie in new
this is crazy man
um
so you know like that was it that was it
we always teased you about hoogies i
know and then you went into hoagies i
went into the hoagie business it's like
when people like when people tell you
who they are
you should listen to them but when your
friends tell you who you are you should
listen and we kept going you're a hoagie
guy holmes it's literally love hoagies
when the guy goes remember when my
teacher said that you couldn't make a
living being funny yes yes
except everybody was like have you
noticed joe's
always two-fist and hoagies this guy's
got a lot of hugs yeah you never you
never beat down the hoagie dream by the
way i'm not just doing this to to you
know lean into your interests i'm legit
invested in that premise
why do sandwiches suck
why do they suck joe because they're not
made properly and when i went when i was
growing up
i know we're two old men but when i was
growing up you could go to a number of
places in the little downtown area in
lexington where i grew up go in and get
like a [__] rocking sandwich like a
great
sandwich and then it all got turned into
well subway had a big part it was a big
part of the problem quiz knows
don't we deserve better than quiznos
don't we i mean i only
just because you heat it up i don't
recognize
blimpy or uh quiznos i just don't even
consider them i recognize subway because
they're there
yes you can't ignore it yes they suck
yes
and their spokesperson
had sex with or tried to have sex he did
something real bad with that
anyway it was
the worst we have a t-shirt we we have a
joey rose's t-shirt we're about to
launch our merch and it just says our
spokesperson isn't in prison
oh my god
do you think subway has ever brought you
up in a meeting
do you think they've ever been like
guys i've been warning you about this
hard date
and they're like get out of here it's a
one-off
kid's a problem baby the um so
so we start
doing the pop-up
we spend i'm not kidding
two months
perfecting the bread recipe we bake the
bread every morning wow we spent two
months perfecting the bread recipe well
it took you four hours to come up with
taste buds i'm not surprised it took you
a few a few weeks to come up with the
bread but it's perfect it's perfect
bread it's perfect bread i think so what
do you it's a it's a hoagie roll it is
but there are this is why you ask the
question why do you say what you suck
yeah and the bread the bread is your is
that's your foundation it's like 90
bread if your bread sucks
yeah
and when i say sucks
i don't just mean the texture and taste
i mean if there's too much of it yep
holmes i'm telling you we went through
like
trial periods before we launched the
pop-up where we were like
how much meat is too much how much is
too little wow
how how long should the roll be
how wide should it be
how do
we make it work
how do we make it a value for eight
dollars but also we still make some kind
of profit yeah
but but the person doesn't feel cheated
you know like it was
it was a lot dude it was a lot but we
figured it out
and we launched the pop-up what
surprised you because i like watching
shows about small businesses and stuff i
think people do so you had this dream
where maybe you can't answer this i
don't i don't want to [__] with your
business but like at some point there
had to be something where you're like
and it's gotta be honey baked ham fake
example everything and someone goes and
someone goes joe the reason why no one
uses honey baked ham is because honey is
actually a sweetener that's imported and
like your overhead like it's you're not
gonna make any pro like at some point
you had to see
make some concession
no you didn't there was no concession
so the way we solved that problem we had
it we did that did come up yeah we have
a sandwich that's that's asiago cheese
genoa salami
prosciutto
and
sweet peppers
the problem with that sandwich was if
you want to use prosciutto you have to
you have to use good prosciutto bad
prosciutto is a nightmare it's
disgusting
and paul was like dude this is not cheap
[__] you know like
this is
right you know
you know so you figure out
okay
how do you make up for that cost in
over here in another item
you know what i mean now your xbox
losing money on the system but making it
on the games so we have a peanut butter
and jelly with ruffles
not ruffles brand but a ruffled potato
chips on it yeah
on the sandwich yeah that sandwich
has a very
low low cost
um yeah you know pro
you know what i'm saying yeah
you it evens itself out it itself
interesting the people eating the pb and
j's they're helping pay for papa
prosciutto over here you live in large
and by the way
don't think that you're getting skimped
on the pb j it is a monstrous sandwich
and you will be just as full and just as
happy and it's an eight dollar pb j uh
buddy
i'm going pbj every day yeah even good
prosciutto i'm like what is this freddy
krueger's nuts
get this [__]
even when i ate meat prosciutto is one
of the most i know you're going to fight
me on this it just tastes like
i don't know i don't know it's an
extremely salty ham i mean it's very
salty but also just the texture reminds
me of biting the corner off my finger
it's like human it's a little too i
would say that you well yeah it's often
cut too thick
okay and that's a problem
it's just i love joey sandwiches these
are all the little things it's like did
you like it does that make you come
alive when you're doing this
so when we first started doing it i was
making the sandwiches yeah at the pop-up
i had nothing else to do yep you know we
we
this might have been pre-taste buds
recordings i don't remember but pat and
i would just record on zoom
yeah
and then um and then so you're saying in
the future heartache restaurants are
gonna have black and white photos of you
actually making the sandwiches like
emblazoned on the wall
it's possible
i don't think so but they're available
they exist
joey i'm calling it now it's happening
oh that's funny
um no but uh
i was i was doing it because i was like
if he's gonna give me a chance to like
do this under his roof and use his staff
yeah
so we can see if it works i got to be
all in and he rose to it yeah and i i
also had to show the guys how to do it
like i made
i made like guides
and are you enjoying this or is this a
drag no i was yeah i was it seemed like
you were and comics were coming in and
fans and yeah fans were always like
i didn't think you'd be here you know
yeah yeah i'm here man i want to make
sure it's good and then keith's in the
corner of course he's here stupid well
keith actually so funny keith was like
god god damn it it's great i hate how i
hate that i like it like that's a merch
shirt yeah
it was very funny he was screaming at me
i uh can i say something that you
probably won't care as much as i want
you to care sure like i want this to be
really sweet but i don't think you're
gonna care but i want you to the
subtitles on are like i love you sure
uh i'm gonna go and i'm gonna eat a
turkey sandwich i know i don't need meat
but that's huge my favorite
sub is turkey and i want the joey roses
that's huge turkey that's you tell me a
little about it
it's turkey with roast beef okay but we
home make the roast beef and
homes i'm telling you you might want to
have the roast beef oh it's it's been
decades since i've had but but if you
really want it with just turkey we can
take the roast beef all right
um
it's got hot cherry peppers on it okay
the best peppers
it's got white american cheese some mayo
salt pepper
tomato onion it sounds great it's when
val was pregnant she also doesn't eat
meat she should have a turkey sub it was
the only thing she wanted it's a very
specific food it's a very crazy turkey
sub seasoned right is awesome it's
unbelievable um
so
fans coming in fans are coming in comics
are coming so funny cipher sounds came
in
he didn't know i was doing it he just
came into the stand for a meeting and he
saw me behind the counter and he's like
is everything all right man because he
thought i just got a job at the stand
and i go no no no no i go i have a
sandwich pop up here i'm doing a
sandwich business and he goes
oh that's [__] dope man i was like
yeah it's kind of cool like so anyway
so during that period
paul was like
you know man like we should talk about a
brick and mortar people are reacting
strongly to this and we started talking
about it and then paul was like you know
we both like the old school bars i was
like yeah and he's like it should be a
bar too it's gonna be a lot easier to
keep the lights on if it's both
and then we were like well let's make it
a place you'd want to hang out in
let's make the best bar
we can think of that would be like our
favorite bar
and what's that
well first we picked the location which
was the lower east side which is sort of
the last bastion of of manhattan of true
manhattan old school manhattan
and then because of the lower east side
we start to be like
what do we want this to be and we were
like we want it to be
like all the social clubs and the movies
we love so much
and then that
expanded into the idea of we want this
place to feel like a cross-section of
all the best
decades
time flies you're talking what time is
it roses that's the 90 minute line
okay cool
we we want it to be a cross-section of
all the greatest decades of new york so
we were like
what's the what is that we're like it's
the 70s and the early 80s
and holmes you want to talk universe
our address is uh
rivington i can't believe i'm blanking
on our address it's on rivington street
yeah um
we we hired an artist
to help us with the design
and we hired two different artists and
i think joe
i had i'm pretty sure
we had a meeting for homeowners
insurance and i'm pretty sure the
company's called rivington partners
really that today
that's weird that's universe that's
universe we when we say universe joe and
i always have these weird
synchronicities like
super blatant like that's weird that's a
good one that's really weird i mean
today i had a meeting with rivington
partners i'm sure of it that's really
weird and you're like it's rivington
weird well but also the fact that
rivington is so significant to what i'm
about to tell you too because that's
rivington is another universe thing
weird
we're on rivington street we have an
artist come in to help us with putting
the design together
uh and we said
i kept explaining this concept
and i said
it's paul's boutique
and she was like what do you mean and i
was like the beastie boys album paul's
boutique it's every cool thing about new
york like it's like it's disco and it's
studio 54 and it's punk rock and it's
hip hop and
i was like it's [__] paul's boutique
and she's like okay i got you i think i
got what you mean
and i find out oh god i'm gonna have to
get a license to ill
it's gonna take six months to get the
license to ill before
before i could break ground on this
oh gotta call my bell
dude
i find out a month later
the front cover
of paul's boutique
was taken on rivington street
three blocks from our bar
because that's where paul's boutique was
oh my [__] and i'm like what the [__]
and then i'm like of course it was
there's a [__] beastie boys mural
there and i never knew why it was there
i thought it was just like a cool mural
whoa
so
then like once that all clicked
then it was like so you yes the bar you
want it to be right
paul was like
he got a screenshot of james consbar in
the movie thief and he was like we're
gonna make our sign look like this and
if you look at the sign in the movie
thief and you look at our bar sign it's
the same sign wow and it when we the
night it lit up i literally teared up i
it's ah [__] it's going to get me god i
don't want to cry
i texted paul a picture of the sign
because he couldn't be there when we
turned it on and he just wrote back we
did it with a picture of the thief sign
it was [__] awesome roses it was our
story is
i just love it i'm loving this chat i'm
sorry to interrupt just to tell you how
great it is it's a great it's a story of
isolation to community yes you know what
i mean yes it's from head to heart it's
from all these unexpected things you
never would have dreamed
moving you
what i kept saying when i moved back was
my biggest problem that i had with the
with the lifestyle of l.a and i don't
mean to knock it i'm not knocking it
please but it's it's suburbia
essentially yeah sure and i said the
ultimate goal is isolation it's to get
the house on the highest hill with the
fence that you want to hear my bit about
the i code yes you want to hear my bit
about go ahead please you're i think
you're gonna love it so america makes up
for like four or five percent of the
world's population might be like four
maybe lower now there's an old statistic
but we use 50 of the resources of the
world which is [__] insane right we
could both write an hour just on that
right i think about like in pee wee
we're we're herman
right you know what i mean we're getting
wearing the three-piece suit at the high
school
has like homemade pudding at lunch and
is like
and lets other kids
smell his seat or something he's like
you should be lucky he got to smell
herman's seat
but here's where it becomes a bet or an
observation at least but then americans
it's like america is our our parents yes
and the way they are in the world trains
us how to be in the country so america
hoards
and then isolates right like who doesn't
want to share i know we share i'm just
saying doesn't share that much same with
americans
our goal like you're saying is to make
tons and tons of money and then move
away from everybody right so you become
a tiny little america
using
you make up four percent of the country
and you're using 50 of or your community
you make up a tiny sliver but you want
to hoard just like we learn to hoard
from our parents right does that make
sense makes perfect sense so that's
that's and that is very evident in l.a
make it
and then break and then yeah and i would
always say the only people you ever see
are the curated group you allow in
past your wall yeah that's right it's
the tony i i struggled with this too
it's the tony stark thing uh i've said
this a million times on this podcast but
doctor strange says to tony stark and
it's a deep burn he goes
unlike you i have friends that don't
work for me and i was like yikes yeah
that hurt that's that's uh that's a hard
one yeah yeah so that's what you said
earlier full circle
which which one of these guys actually
has friends that's right yeah that's
what that's why i i'm interested in yeah
so and that's why i value you so much
yeah as a friend yeah same thing yeah
so so i said that that was la right but
i said what i liked about new york was
it was about integration
you can't live in new york without a
goal of yours being
complete integration it has to be
i was like you you could be donald trump
living on the top floor of trump tower
you still have to go down the elevator
through the lobby
and you're getting your newspaper at the
same [__] stand i buy my friend
you're going to the same coffee shop
you're the guy in the in the cabbies cat
be like hey mr t
you see the headlines tonight
every john mulaney voice
so uh
and and that's what i like about new
york yeah i know so so it goes from a
story of complete isolation to truly a
story about
integration and connection
not just because it's new york and not
just because it's with friends and doing
a new thing but also homes because
during the pandemic
the idea the original idea of the the
sandwiches that are affordable but great
it grew into this whole other thing
because we were watching the city
collapse
and we were we were sitting there going
[__] you and your 22 craft cocktail
we're sick of it
i we want to open a place where you can
come and sit for hours and spend 40
bucks
and eat
and drink
come get drunk for 20 bucks you know
what i mean like
and that everything
that it that was the indicator of every
single decision made in the bar
the and then we started putting
ourselves into it the entire wall behind
the bar is
our video vintage video discs that paul
found at a thrift store in detroit
of all the movies we love in classic you
mean laserdisc there's a there was a
there was a laserdisc competitor that
was called a video disc and this is that
wow um but it comes in a plastic the
disc itself is in a case with the
artwork on it and you would put the
whole thing into the machine
wow so you can buy one of these and it's
just like a mini disk yeah it's a piece
of wall art wow so it's it's it so all
these movies that we love are behind the
bar the entire bar top
is well um
um
no well that's what's funny it was
supposed to be it's a 45 minute yeah
yeah we would
we had simpsons we come back it's dark
out
i'm not even here and you go
wood
the bar was wood
that's a great simpsons jerk oh they do
it a lot that's perfect um
it's um
oh for crisix i'm blanking on the term
when you put the clear stuff down and it
hardens it's like a resin
epoxy yeah so we did an epoxy bar top
the entire bar top
is a collage of
of classic new york hip-hop
flyers and posters some of which came
from my childhood bedroom wow
yeah yeah there's yeah
we made the this one we didn't have to
epoxy
it just stuck right on there because it
came from joe derosa's
childhood bedroom can i start you with
some asiago sandwiches
you know what we're good
oh my god
i feel like the roasting level has been
just right it's good it's not heavy
you're coming in with with jokes when we
need them otherwise it's just a heavy
story no i love the store huh i'm really
no i'm saying you're peppering i
appreciate it a banana pepper a banana
or cherry pepper not cherry
pepper we made the back room look like
an old
like steak house like
you know like the bathrooms look sort of
studio 54s they've got mirrored cereal
ceilings and gold leaf walls like we
just took new way to check out your
neighbor's dick yeah well it's a one man
at a time oh yeah yeah
it's it's the most coke looking bathroom
of all time that only one guy can go
into perfect yes
it's it's every single piece of it it's
funny some people have visited the bar
and go this sort of feels like your
apartment
because oh it does sound like your
apartment a little bit right like my
star wars arcade machine is in the bar
wow you know like like that's great so
anyway so you're really putting yourself
into it like there's vulnerability here
the kind of vulnerability that requires
friends yeah not to mention that my face
is on the logo which is very
uncomfortable wow but um and i did not
want that but paul
wanted it i'm saying that because i
don't want to sound like an [__] and
i was like put my face on it put my face
on the sandwich
put me on
the this
board
the uh
and then get the jar you get the chalk
asiago
and you draw yourself i mean we said we
wouldn't go near it but uh a b c asiago
bread cheese
a-i-d-a
no forget it
it's too hot to rip what a-i-d-a means
so
and then we open the doors
and then [__] omicron hits oh yeah
and it's just like son of a [__]
uh
uh but
it's been amazing
the the influx and support that we got
initially
strictly from the comedy community
and then the neighborhood started to
come in and then and it's like you know
big j was telling me and this is really
touching he was like he's like dude
you're like a [__] comedy stop like
he's like
people fly in because they want to see
this show and they want to see legion of
skanks live and he was like they always
go we first stop was joey rose's
sandwich you know like wow it's [__]
wild like part of the tour yeah people
were in the other day
and they were like oh my god like
you're here this is cool you know which
is always really sweet you just wake up
under
newspapers have no one else to go
of course i'm here
you just go back in the pigeon lands on
your head
am i dreaming it does you mean that's
what i thought that's
a little more twilight zone
this is the dream i'm here
none of it has happened but they were
like dude we drove down 90 minutes from
connecticut like
people drove in from ohio wow like it's
wild that's [__] what and i'm always
like
please tell me you're doing something
else
while you're here yeah yeah yeah yeah
and sometimes they aren't so i guess
they're not so there's like now [__] it
man we just wanted to check it out
we also want to try big j's hot sauces
but this is it
i understand who is gomez does relish
and
then we're driving back to the buckeye
state
it's so funny i keep talking to tom papa
about this but he makes bread all the
time and i'm like let's do a thing with
your bread do a papa store yeah yeah
papa's
papa's tapas papa papa's tapas that's
where you should do that
papa's tapas and then the the like the
log line is we didn't just do it because
it rhymes i actually there's like all
this text i actually love tapas
the um
uh
but we got to do things we got through
common
what was the big j thing it was just
that it was just tour stop oh yeah but
we got through omicron
it's been incredible
uh the most flattering thing that
happens is sometimes uh a very old
person and i shouldn't say very old
person you know what i mean a legit old
person will come in
and and say like i haven't seen a place
like this in years in this neighborhood
like it's i'm like holy [__] man we
[__] did it like yeah everybody's
like how long have you been open or like
since november they're like
what
this looks like it's been here for like
forever wow um
it all just came together
so here we are
end of the story
joey rose's is up and running and
flourishing and being enjoyed well he's
not running
taste buds is like going strong we'll
see you in hell's going strong
i'm back out on the road for the first
time
really since all of it
ticket sales are
way up
because of these other things
that's great like this it's it was a
whole reestablishing and rebirth
into a career that when i left this city
i thought might be done wow
like you know so good joe wild
i love do you know that speaking of
keaton i can't that was in that story
was at least an hour long that's wild oh
yeah like when you asked that i was like
huh i was thinking this will take me
about 15 minutes
i love uh the movie the founder
founder yeah yeah i'm loving it
yeah it's developing mcdonald's yeah i
steal i steal paul i steal everything
out for wonderful
yeah that's what no a third guy would
come and steal everything and be and
then at the end he'd go you know why i
stole it the name
hard eight
just sounds like america to me
it's funny i watched that movie when we
were building the bar which
opening that type of business in new
york city
i'm sure
i can't i can only speak to it those
specifics because that's what i
experienced
it was the most stressful thing i have
ever done
ever
i mean waking up
night after night
like at 5 00 a.m like
literally like waking up like who do you
think you are what are you [__] crazy
yeah called cuts called sweats
it's the old adage
you go into cold cuts you've got some
problems coming your way like nuts man
yeah you know you it's terrifying but
exhilarating the reason i brought up the
founder was for the past hour i've been
listening to this story and i've been
like legit enthralled i do love you i'm
sort of you know what i mean like i'm
more interested than most but i'm also
like this is like a great story
that's why you getting kicked in the
nuts at the beginning part was so
essential the zoom with your mom
right i'm coming up but i can't right
big j coming in in a corn t-shirt
and rescuing you eating corn
also eating corn
corned beef
it's not gonna be a vegetable the only
vegetable that jay eats is corn b
um joe i realize i have a gift for you
this is no [__] it's on the desk katie
see that this is gonna sound silly you
see that napkin
i got this for you
no [__]
and i just realized i was gonna mail it
to you
whoa i only got i got it for you what
was it from like the premiere of the
carl the premiere of the carlin thing
and yes a drink was put on it not me i
was mad when someone did that but it's
just the seven words you can't say and i
got it as my bookmark for my book boom
yeah that's about right
that's what i wanted you to say it's
listen it's it's a lovely gift it's a
dirty napkin it's a little gross no i
know i didn't do that i didn't do that
that's no i mean it that's about right
put it in the put it in the cadillac
book
so joey we're almost out of time you
don't want to lose it no no you're a
beautiful man
uh we're almost out of time it's so this
really is the sleepy summer series i
forgot that this happened it only
happens every year for the past 10 years
that every every summer we don't have ac
in the studio so we just kind of like
have these like lower you put ac in the
studio well we have it it's right there
but it's too loud
you have it
that was so good
yeah
that
was oh that was one of my favorite
you looked at me
with pure incredulity
just
yeah
turn it on
that's the it's jackie brown it's it's
jackie brown it's jackie brown it's not
it's jackie brown it's the line it's
jackie brown in jackie where he goes
when sam jackson goes
you mean to tell me
you saw the bail bonds in the store and
you thought nothing of it
within here when he kills the hero
and he goes and it's paul quotes it to
me all the time when he's breaking my
balls he always goes he used to be
beautiful man
because that's what he says as de niro's
dying wow he goes you used to be
beautiful man because he can't believe
the [__] up
wow and you didn't think any that that
was it you just told me you saw max
cherry in the department store played by
robert forster
wow
someone's getting all these references
but it's not me and i'm did you never
see jackie brown i've seen it but not as
much as i've seen i've seen almost every
tarantino movie many many times do
yourself a favor revisit yeah
it's
it's one that you got to see a couple
times to really love it yeah
it's way funnier than you remember it
being
you have to watch jackie brown without
pulp fiction on your mind i see
pulp fiction had come out we all thought
it was going to be another pulp fiction
it's not it's a different movie yeah and
you have to now go back and watch it
know english once upon a time in
hollywood and all that stuff yeah and
you'll be like this movie is i'm not
saying it wasn't amazing when it came
out but it you weren't really i love it
yeah we we wanted more
yeah you're like why is it being told
linearly
literally
yeah yeah you know the word
here's the you know it's silly
because i thought we would actually talk
about this for the majority of the
podcast but here we are and you have
another show to get to but you
tell the story why did you you called me
recently are you comfortable telling the
story is that something we can talk
about
i talked about it yesterday on sibley
okay
yeah all right then guys what was the
segura earlier
that's sibling are you sickler
goddamn a lot of s's who did you do
sibley no i did honey i did sickler yeah
tuesday
tuesday i love sinclair i was eating
fruit salad before we went into the
studio
and there was honeydew in it and without
even realizing i'm about to do a show
called honeydew i put it on my fork and
i went
i started walking away and he goes what
are you about to do man what are you
about to do i go i'm throwing away this
[__] honey dude he started laughing
so hard
and he's like let me tape it let me tape
it oh because you don't like honeydew i
was like it's a [__] fruit it's
worthless look at it it looks like it's
gonna be bursting with lime and flavor i
don't think you've had a proper honeydew
[__] off i've had it plenty of times
this is like with this is
this there are three
things people do this with
and i've had it
number one cantaloupe and honeydew
uh-huh number two
weed
number three
vegan cheese
anytime you go i hate one of those
things so he goes i don't think you've
had the proper i've had all of them and
they all suck
every weed
every vegan cheese
and every melon
i want to say
i thought cantaloupe was honeydew is
honey do the like white one honeydew is
the greenish white one yeah that one
sucks yeah you're cool because you think
it's gonna taste yeah do you think it's
gonna be good
it's gonna be limey and refreshing yeah
no no yeah but i do like cantaloupe you
into cantaloupe i hate cantaloupe this
guy with the with the fruits no i'm
serious though why did you get a fruit
salad if you don't like nowadays because
there was only two pieces of honeydew
what it was mostly pineapple which i
love i love it i'm the palette yeah of a
child
pineapple is like it's like a gateway
fruit it's like come on i know you've
been having sour patch kids but we got a
party over here too look at my fun spiky
hair
i'm
i'm like guy fieri he's gonna say place
into this guy fieri of fruits it's like
the most undeniable right yeah
and when you eat it it tastes like sugar
candy
but then you can't make the leap to
honeydew buddy i gotta tell you is like
you know your in-laws you marry
pineapple but you gotta have cantaloupe
no no you gotta
exactly it's like the in-law dinner you
don't wanna have to go to
you're obligated and you gotta it yes
but that should not be an obligation it
should be a joyous experience
i hate the melon i hate watermelon i
hate pineapple honeydew and watermelon i
hate it here we go let me guess i
haven't had the right one right
watermelon yeah i hate it water i hate
it
i hate it why
i'm gonna wager a guest because your
body is so brittle
and malnourished that the water content
of it makes bowels start moving and
gurgling
and you and you have to like you can't
handle it it's a fair guess
but you answered your question with your
mockery of me yes
it's water
it's delicious
i'll i'll go eat a [__] ice cube
and guess what i won't have to deal with
seeds
have i just written a new bit about
watermelon yeah i think you did oh i
thought you were dipping into the taste
buds archive no no we just argued
watermelon and i lost terribly because
he i i'm also now appreciating how good
sal is
against yeah uh because you need that
you need that what are you talking about
hot day hot day you go home you have a
slice of watermelon your mom cuts you a
nice triangle of watermelon holds
together it's got good like structural
integrity that's exactly that's a really
good that's a good impression
you'll i'm embarrassed about what i took
that i lost with what do you mean
the fruit i lost to watermelon with i'm
embarrassed is it pineapple
raisins
for those of you not dying with laughter
the concept of taste buds is you're
arguing that raisins
are better than are better and here's
salad on raisins raisins or what the
crazy old lady with the lights off on
halloween
if you go up to a door and and you
insist joe joe joe if you insist she
comes out and gives you a a dry
crusted box of raisins you brought up
halloween when you get the box erasers
yes
and you want to burn their house down
and if you do and you're caught they say
you were right they gave him they gave
him some sun raisins can we clip it can
we isolate it can we clip it can we get
it to shower yes he's gonna see this
impression he writes down the clips it's
a perfect impression of sal it's so good
it's perfect well i called him better
holmes and i'm glad that we uh
his last name is end gardens
yeah okay so tell me tell me about why
you called me the other day
this sounds so like i'm loading can i'll
just say you called me basically wanted
to talk about the meaning of life i
wanted to talk about spirituality
spirituality and i'm just curious
outside of a church
yes definition of it yeah outside of
organized religion approach to it
because yes i said to you in so many
words and it does relate to the story
today
i should be happy
i should be happier than i am why do i
have such a sense of dread about the
future and yeah and i kind of narrowed
in on
because i'm making it all about me
there's something bigger than me
and i'm just not connecting to it or
focusing on it and whether that bigger
thing is
the stars in the sun or the universe or
a power or whatever i don't know
i just know that i need to get out of
this and like that's right into that
so and i called you and i said
i think i'm only saying that's right
because i have that revolution all the
time
i just don't want to sound condescending
like that's right joe welcome to the
party you did it by the way i love that
that's the thing you thought would sound
condescending you've
well you haven't been running
you got to meet 10 minutes ago
yeah it's just a montage from the whole
podcast as the curb your
place enthusiasm
it
oh my god
it doesn't make sense but i want to call
you paul giamatti's cheat day i don't it
doesn't even make sense
but so so like
you you're not just a dear friend and
not just a dear friend that's
into this stuff and practices it
but also out of everybody i know
the most equipped
to be able to talk
because i do know people that are
religious
my parents
yeah you're the per and more than that
too but like but you're the person that
was so equipped
to actually take it out of all the stuff
that usually gets in my way yeah and
and i said to you i said
i somehow
i was driving
i had my phone plugged in and i had it
was i was listening to youtube clips i
was watching them
and somehow i get onto a youtube clip of
larry the cable guy talking about his
christianity yeah and
so much of what he said about just the
practice of life made sense to me
he lost me when it started to get into
the church talk and the and the
which is a shame by the way i'm not
putting down larry i'm just saying
there's certain areas for me too
that you can be saying something that
i'm just so into and as soon as you get
into like uh
for me it's like us them in out heaven
hell we have it they don't something
exclusive something exclusionary
something fear-based i usually and i
haven't heard the talk you're talking
about that i it's such a shame that
there aren't more places where you can
have
safe conversations about spirituality
yeah and there was and and not that he
was you know prickish or anything yeah
he was just talking but there was a
rigidity to it that i was not there was
a rigidity to it that the sleevelessness
could not relieve him he was sleeved he
was foolishly
yeah
uh
but no but it was there was a rigidity
that i couldn't
i was like there i'm hearing that tone
of the priests i knew growing up yep and
it snails on a chalkboard right yeah and
um
and i said
to ryan yesterday
i said i i i look at it like the way a
lot of people look at aa
a lot of people go into aaa and they go
you got to get past the god part
they're going to keep saying god in here
that's going to turn you off if you're
not a god guy you know
don't worry about that
get to what they're telling you to do
about sobriety yeah and that to me is
the thing and i told you you sent me the
richard rohr video which was amazing yep
i sent it to my mom oh wow i haven't
discussed it with her yet but i sent it
to her and i called her when i sent it
to her and i said i think i finally
found you yes
i said i think i finally found the thing
uh that will
create some sort of common ground for us
in the world of spirituality
wow uh by the way so much of my
spirituality was was rooted and
encouraged by wanting to reconcile and
reconnect with my mom
which is that's interesting it motivates
it i'm not saying it was the point of it
but i'd uncover something that rescued
some sort of language or some sort of
worldview or just some sort of
perspective and i would i just couldn't
wait to share it with her and when it
comes to like richard rohr she's she's
into it too it's it's incredible that
there's something i could send to my mom
and joe derosa and both of you guys are
like this is [__] great well and i
said it's funny because i said to my mom
pete holmes sent me this and she knows
you from
she was from she would watch the show
yeah but uh
so so that was like an interesting
little detail you know but uh she um
and i he's i believe he's jesuit correct
uh franciscan franciscan okay very
similar to the jesus i said yeah i said
jesuit to my mom and she said oh that's
interesting that jesuits is very liberal
with with and i said well maybe that's
what it is
but
i said he's just he equates prayer to
meditation which i've done for years
but he finally explained like why
they're similar
you know
in in let me let me rephrase that he he
made an analogy that wasn't negative
i always made a very negative analogy
with that i would always go oh prayer
it's meditation
it's your it's your whiskey it's
whatever it's your tune out you know
what i mean
and that's a very obviously jaded way to
look at it but when you're not
feeling hopeful about the world you know
that's how you look at things
this was way more like just like
you know just the idea of like once the
thing that he said that really resonated
was once he said
when he goes prayer or meditation
basically goes whatever you want to call
it like you know and then he said
when you're when there's no goal
and we're putting everything in the
perspective of
if you're praying to save grandma
you're you shouldn't be praying
which is so interesting because i do
like meditation
and every time and i do think it's
similar to prayer but every time my mom
has ever said you should pray for so and
so i i know you're not religious but
i've said no
and because i'm like it's to me it's an
absurd thing to do
and him saying that again the negative
or jaded way to say it is oh yeah mom
god's gonna save mrs
tullio or you know who was a neighbor of
our that passed i'm not [__] on her
i'm just saying
because you because you prayed or
whatever yeah yeah she was a very nice
lady but you know what i mean it's like
that's the jaded way
the richard war
positive way is
you shouldn't be trying to trade favors
with whoever the higher power is
you know
it's not about that it's about you
staying connected to that to that thing
and saying like a flow too it's like
it's like being quiet enough to hear
where you belong like your story had a
lot of flow in it the story of your life
right
your recent life has a lot of like
being quiet enough and still enough to
hear
what you need
and to ask for it and receive it and go
with it and to trust and surrender and
that's a lot of what richard is about
it's he's all about the 12 steps by the
way he thinks that aaa and programs like
a.a have the brokenness that's missing
in christianity like a lot of
christianity is so like shiny i'm
speaking about in my own experience it's
very shiny it's very white teeth white
people white khakis you know like very
shiny it's like sort of a religion for
winners and i said this to you and i've
said it a million times on this podcast
people have heard me say this but
richard says he's like the fact that
that's the spokesperson for that faith
is a naked jewish loser who's being
murdered like who's powerless like
that's the spokesperson for a religion
that we turned into like
you know help me win the super bowl help
me win the client help me win help me
win help me help me never lose and we
turn it into another way to be like even
when i die i win right you know what i
mean where it's like no and i told you
this because i thought you would because
you're this way right we like getting
real and a little bit fierce with things
richard taught me that like baptism is a
drowning ritual it's supposed to be like
die
now don't wait till you die
but get low now right realize you're
full of [__] now realize it's also
beautiful i'm not saying it's not
beautiful it's a paradox it's beautiful
but it's also not
real and when you let it go the paradox
is the more of it you get the richer
experience of it you get but you can't
cling to it so there's all this like
fierce imagery of like
death and and and rebirth and all the
stuff but we've just turned it into like
no win
as an american pursue the american dream
get ready god bless america and then
when you die you also get to go to
another gated community
yeah that was an interesting thing he
said
we oh it's 2 55. i thought we've been
going for two hours and 55 minutes he he
okay
i'll be quick but he he said uh
the just the thing he said about um i'm
gonna have to watch it a couple times
it's a lot of information but
the stuff i gleaned at least on this
first time uh he said um
you you you can
it's funny holmes it's glenn gary
he goes
if you want to go to hell you're you can
do it right now yeah if you want to go
to heaven you can do it right your voice
says you can live in it it's hell all
the way to hell is something that he
says hell on earth i won't live in it i
won't live in it it's wild yeah that is
wild yeah because and that's his whole
thing it's like heaven
is a state that you start now it's a yes
to reality it's a it's a merging with
reality it's a forgiving he's all about
forgiving reality that you're not in
control that things aren't happening the
way that you would want them that you
can't understand it but you that you
show up humble and small anyway and and
it's it's all about surrender in that
way it's interesting yeah and also too
when you take away the concept that
there's a guy
that's gonna give you things in exchange
for behaviors yep
um
and then turn it into no it's about
surrendering surrendering yourself to
reality and whatever now obviously
richard ruhr believes that there is a
god and
i'm sure he believes that we go
somewhere after this ends
and maybe that is the case i don't know
but let's say it isn't let's say worst
case scenario let's say you die and
that's it you're dead yeah
this still
makes sense to me
as a lifestyle and that's what i was
trying to get to
that's that to me is what's the
important part it's not about
at least now
it's not about but i want to have faith
in a lord or whatever it's about i want
to
surrender to reality and be a natural
part of this whole thing
instead of focusing on myself
and basically looking at a clicking
clock or ticking clock and going
well and then and then you die and then
that's it you know what i mean that's it
remember i told you when you called me
that religion and richard taught me this
his religio and lio comes from the word
ligament at same route and it's to
reconnect you so it's supposed to make
you feel at home in this that's what
taylor tomlinson did this podcast
yesterday we were talking about the
space photos and she was like did that
freak you out and i was like no because
the same thing that's animating that is
animating me i'm i'm in the space photos
you know the the new telescope photos of
the galaxy there's some new photos oh i
didn't see them so it's like
this is hundreds of thousands like an
unimaginable number of planets that are
in these systems and i'm like the same
operating principles that are behind
those are behind me
and i we were talking about like it's an
alan watts quad i'm not a stranger here
like i i'm not a visitor you know what i
mean and that's that's religio that's
going like you're not a mistake it's not
a flaw right in fact this whole thing
is like joe fits perfectly into it you
know what i mean intuit is even
misleading you are it it's all this it's
all uh you're already home
and and then prayer heaven hell and and
contemplation is what richard's all
about too which is meditating basically
with your eyes open not with a mantra
but looking at all of reality and just
saying yes to it and allowing it to
change you being vulnerable enough to
let a tree
and its existence have an impact on your
heart getting quiet enough to marvel at
the fact that the same thing that's
looking out me is looking at you and
here we are on a couch and we're just
like not just as a thought experiment
but to get
joy
connection
life
i mean i even though i know these things
i still watch too much tv and jerk off
and all this stuff and i'm like i want
to i want to get
that good stuff
the better stuff yeah well i think it's
little
things
i i'm always speaking from my
perspective but i can only
i can only break it down into little
things
so like one thing i'm trying to do now
is
uh
because the little things will lead to
the bigger things in theory right
but one thing i'm trying to do now and
it's funny this actually came from larry
the cable guys video oh wow
and
catholics would call it grace
but i am trying to consciously take a
moment before i eat
to
not say thank you to anybody
to recognize the fact
that i am able to feed myself again it's
mindful you're being mindful yeah
and again some people say it's a moment
to thank god or jesus or buddha whoever
to me
it's just
as you said being mindful it's taking a
beat to go a lot of people can't do what
i just did
once
in a month let alone
any time i want to yeah you know what i
mean that's right
it's it's a huge thing and that's
successful today huh five six seven
eight times okay
it's funny i i i dodged the joke because
i almost said it was there i almost said
once in a month
and i was going how am i going to eat
this month and i was like don't do it
that's all right yes
they smell yeah but um
you know i i talked to christa stefano
about this stuff a lot
because he's
he's a very aware guy you know like like
you know his his
he's a very funny guy and his online
persona is him
but it's very you know it's very light
and it's very silly and whatever but he
is a deep guy like and he will and and
being in this business
is a mind [__]
and that's one of the things i'll talk
to him about i'll just say chris you
know like
i know for a fact
i will very likely never have the
amounts of money that some of my dear
friends have
i might never own a giant house
it's
it doesn't matter like
i'm grateful for the [__] i do have
because my god almighty how much worse
could it be it could be a zillion times
worse and that's not me
gloating in what i have versus what
somebody doesn't
but if i'm going to sit in in a paid in
a in a rent
in an apartment i easily pay rent for in
new york city
every month because i am in a nice
apartment now you know
every month two windows yeah
baby
but if i'm gonna sit in an apartment in
new york city that i pay my rent for
easily every month i pay my bills easily
every month i feed myself multiple times
a day
in that apartment or out of it
i am surrounded by video games and
things that i love to buy and collect
and have fun and enjoy
i'm gonna sit here and go it's
my life sucks
because i don't own a giant house yeah
that's insane yeah off of jokes off of
dumb [__] jokes i would go a little
bit further and say that those things
that you have in your house aren't
actually
what make you happy
those because i loved your apartment i
always used to love going over there
would
watch me eat smoke a cigarette
yeah and and they're your toys i
actually think they help you
get into a state where you're calm
enough
to recognize this is very lofty but
recognize your nature like they calm you
down they bring you some nostalgia they
bring you some diversion but they allow
you to rest in what i'm gonna call your
your true nature your true self which is
like that talk and you're there and
you're happy what i'm saying is and this
is truly this is like yeah after we
cover our richard rohr stuff we'll get
into our rupert spire and we'll have all
these fun things but like the truth is
uh the stuff out there
it's a broken model
going out for happiness and i do it too
but going out getting momentarily happy
and being sad then going out sometimes
in the same day seven eight times and
rupert spyro who i love says that's like
thinking it's normal to be healthy and
then sick and then healthy and then sick
he's like peace
is your natural state and by the way
that's what meditation is that's what
deep sleep is
rupert says that we're not unconscious
when we're in deep sleep it's not the
absence of awareness it's the awareness
of absence nothing's going on so there's
nothing to report or remember but there
is an experience like when you have deep
sleep there is an experience it's not
just nothing and then you're bad right
there was an experience and he's saying
so does ramona march he say that's
because your truest who you are when you
close your eyes and i did this with
taylor she did not fight it was like
when you look at
what your awareness is it's boundless
it's infinite there's no boundary on the
other side of which it isn't right
that's you
and when these things it's not a big
house and it's not your he-man
collection or whatever i'm not even
breaking your balls no no i know it's
not the choice it's the stuff that helps
us
rest and relax and and drop the game get
off the treadmill i would i would say um
i
i think i agree with that
but i also the the
my take one of my other takeaways from
the roar video was
you can have a possession you just don't
cling to it that's right and that
valerie and i say eckhart tolle goes i
like nice things
and he's like the most yeah i think he's
an enlightened being and he's going
around he's like i have a high thread
count bed yeah yeah but it doesn't
define him right exactly and that's kind
of how i look at it it's like i love
buying the new
you know complete friday the 13th
blu-ray franchise set yeah because it's
got a cool box and it looks really neat
on my shelf and yeah and at any time i
have a movie marathon at my fingertips i
love that yeah
but if it was stolen from me i'm not
gonna be like right well now what am i
going to do
well when it comes to people's and
happiness because i i have i have funky
chunky days all the time where i'm just
pinched it's like that eminem lyric
where he's like some days i just feel
like my father i hate to be bothered
which by the way to interject yeah are
you keeping up with oldham because
what's up he's doing his best work ever
oh really those like music to be
murdered by records yeah are like the
best things he's done oh really yeah and
kamikaze i like kamikaze it's like that
extended there's a few tracks i skip on
kamikaze are you checking the time yeah
that's actually 307 sorry you got to go
yeah i think so
just i don't know how long it takes to
get to studio city from here yeah you
should go okay no no no it's not it's
not that but yeah okay you gotta say
keep it christy this guy's already
getting that oh sorry i'm sorry we're
talking about god i'm about to tell you
about looking for happiness and
objective reality
uh i will plug it here rupert spyra has
a book called
you are the happiness you're looking for
which is just a brilliant book and it's
about what we're talking about um
all right can i plug
i mean you're gonna plug on top of
rupert go ahead
well joey roses yeah please come
we're open tuesday through sunday that's
this that's the sandwich shop yeah
sandwich shop and bar um please come
through uh we're at 174 remington street
new york city handed that out you can go
to
joeyrosesnyc.com for all the details
joey rose's that guy was taken
no it was
no we weren't there was it was because
we wanted everything out of that it
doesn't matter
jesus christ
joeyrosesyc.com for details check it out
uh please come see us and uh and then
also i'm i don't know when this comes
out but i'm i'm back on the road uh
my next dates are mid-august in atlantic
city and i'm going all over the place so
go to joederosainfo.com
for tickets and show details
and uh yeah that's it all right i could
riff on your website for a while but
you gotta go
would you say keep it crispy joey i love
you buddy keep it crispy
all three cameras this guy's a [__]
promo
you